hello everyone and welcome back to
Simply learns YouTube channel ethical
hacking is the practice of using hacking
techniques to test the security of a
computer system Network or application
with the goal of identifying
vulnerabilities and improving the
overall security of the system with
increasing Reliance on digital systems
in various Industries there has been a
growing demand for skilled ethical
hackers ethical hacking offers a
lucrative career option with a high
salary and the potential to work as a
freelancer or as a part of a team with
that being said it is sufficiently
evident that cyber security and ethical
hacking are amazing career options for
every individual out there so without
any further delay let's jump on to our
topic right away if you want to enter
the field of cyber security and grab a
high-paying job then simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with the MIT University
is surely the right option for you
cyber security will help you learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance
you'll get foundational to Advanced
skills through industry-leading cyber
security certification courses in this
program for admission to this post
graduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50 or higher
grades and candidates with one plus year
of work experience are before
so join now the course link is mentioned
in the description box below let us
start by understanding what ethical
hacking is
ethical hacking often referred to as
white attacking involves using your
cyber security skills to protect systems
and networks in 2024 this field is more
critical than ever due to the increasing
number of cyber attacks your role as an
ethical hacker is to find
vulnerabilities before malicious hackers
do and secure digital environments
before we begin let's talk about the
prerequisites to excel in ethical
hacking you should have a strong
foundation in computer science or ID
familiarity with programming languages
like python C plus and Java will be
beneficial as they are commonly used in
cyber security tasks it's essential to
follow a structured learning path so
start by gaining a deep understanding of
networking you need to comprehend how
data flows through networks the various
protocols in use and security mechanisms
that protect them next delve into the
world of operating systems understanding
the intricacies of most popular
operating systems like Windows Linux and
Mac OS is crucial for ethical hackers
you'll often encounter vulnerabilities
at this level
certifications play a pivotal role in
your ethical hacking career consider
pursuing certifications like certified
ethical hacker certified information
system Security Professionals CompTIA
Security Plus and certified information
security manager cism these
certifications are recognized by
industry professionals and can open up
doors to many exciting job opportunities
learning by doing is crucial in ethical
hacking engage in Hands-On experiences
such as capture deflect competitions
participating in bug bounties and
setting up your own home lab
these activities will sharpen your
practical skills and deepen your
understanding of vulnerabilities and
exploits cyber security is a rapidly
evolving field stay updated with the
latest threats tools and techniques by
following cyber security news attending
conferences and engaging with online
communities the ability to adapt to New
Challenges is a Hallmark of successful
ethical hacker ethical hacking is all
about doing good always are there to the
law obtain proper permission when
testing systems and respect privacy and
confidentiality ethical behavior is not
just a requirement it's a Cornerstone of
this profession
as you progress build a strong portfolio
document your achievements successful
hacks and projects a well-maintained
portfolio will not only showcase your
skill but also make you stand out to
potential employers
building strong networking skills is
essential attend cyber security
conferences and join professional
associations like Issa information
system security Association or isaca
information systems audit and Control
Association networking not only enhances
your knowledge but also opens doors to
job opportunities and collaborations
coding and scripting are your secret
weapons Master scripting languages like
Python and Powershell these skills are
invaluable when automating security
tasks creating custom tools and
analyzing malwares
incident response is a critical aspect
of cyber security understand how to
detect respond to and recover from
security incidents familiarize yourself
with incident response Frameworks like
nist and ISO 27001 this expertise is
highly sought after by organizations
looking to bloster their cyber defenses
don't underestimate the importance of
soft skills effective communication
teamwork and problem solving abilities
will set you apart in the workplace
ethical hackers often collaborate with
cross-functional teams and strong
interpersonal skills are essential for
success
in this ever-evolving field continuous
learning is your best friend
stay curious and explore some emerging
Technologies like Ai iot and Quantum
Computing as they bring new security
challenges learning about these
Technologies and their Associated
security risks will make you an
invaluable asset to any organization
join online communities and forums where
ethical hackers share knowledge and
experiences platforms like GitHub and
stack Overflow can be invaluable for
collaboration and learning engaging with
the community allows you to tap into the
collective wisdom of experienced hackers
looking ahead consider specializations
with ethical hacking such as mobile
security IIT security or Cloud security
these niches offer exciting career paths
and opportunities to become an expert in
a specific area of cyber security
ethical hacking is a field that will
continue to grow in coming years and you
can upskill yourself to start your
professional career in this amazing
field
so let's take a minute to hear it out
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hi I'm
Philip I'm 61 years old and last year I
upskilled with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the I.T sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course of course I must say was
packed with practical examples it was
led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened on the
first
and with that we have come to the end of
this at
up for 2024. if you still have any
questions or any doubts regarding to any
of the topics we have covered in this
video then please feel free to drop them
down in the comment section below and a
team of experts will definitely answer
them for you so thank you so much for
being here we'll see you next time until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply learn for more updates
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign